From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Today is Tuesday, September 13, 2011. My name is Joe Mosnier, I'm the Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm with the videographer John Bishop, we are in St. Augustine Florida at the Bayfront Hilton Hotel.
To do a set of interviews related to civil rights history in St. Augustine with various folks and were delighted and very privileged to sit down Mr. Purcell Maurice Conway.
Thank you very much for taking time and being so flexible today. It's been a little bit unusual as we've bounced out our day, but thank you for sitting down.
Any comments, John, for the take on Noxby?
We are not recording to Ex-D and I think with to the Ex-D cars and I think with that we can begin.
I would like to thank you for taking the time to document this.
I did forget one thing on the tape and I need to say I beg your pardon. This is a civil rights history project interview for joint sponsors, the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture and the Library of Congress for giving me.
I started by just my history of growing up in St. Augustine, particularly Lincolnville, it's a black, self-sufficient community.
I recall early on just the feel of Lincolnville, it was a heavenly place to grow up. All the adults knew you. I knew most of the kids in Lincolnville.
I was raised after the age of five by my great-great-grandmother, Mr. Jorobinson. She was a Seminole Indian and Spanish mixed.
She raised me with the understanding that I would acknowledge the adults, be respectful, don't steal, don't lie. That's how I was raised.
My mother and father and my three brothers moved out to a brand new development in West Augustine and that's where they reside on Scotts Street.
The rotting subdivision, newly developed. I recall as a child getting up in the morning, I could run from sun up to sun down throughout Lincolnville with no problems.
I was no concern about the children because all the adults in Lincolnville were watched out for the children. I spent most of my time, particularly at the little links, which is also housing the Galimore Center today.
It was the only black park in St. Augustine. It's the only place blacks could go for recreation. There was a lot of recreation when I was growing up.
You had football teams organized throughout the city. You had softball games with the adults at night. We had an instructor there, Mr. Eddie Lee Vickers, who ran the facility.
I was amazed that you could go in. You had ping pong, you had pool tables. You had all sorts of activities. Even the man was training some of the kids to play tennis, archery. I was just amazed you could do all this for nothing.
I would spend most of my time as a youth. There was a little links. The biggest problem growing up as a child is money. Money was very scarce.
I called off and thinking, well, I got to find a way to put a little change in my pockets for my candy and ice cream because my great grandmother just didn't have it all the time.
I never get to go to Washington Street one day. I saw these white people boys on their bicycles riding away from the St. Augustine record. I'm thinking, wow.
I was not supposed to go in that part of town. That was a white area. It was only a block across from Washington Street. That was a white area. You didn't go there unless you were accompanied by an adult.
I would stay in there daily and watch these white people boys riding away from the St. Augustine record. I worked up the courage one day. I was 10 years old to venture over there and ask for a job.
I went in and I called speaking to this white gentleman and I'd say, well, look. I like to be a paper boy. Can I be a paper boy? He looked down and he said, well, how old are you? I told him I was 10.
He said, well, okay. I'll give you a try. Come back tomorrow. I left there happy as a log. I went in and I told my great grandma, I said, mama, I got a job as a paper boy.
She was happy. She said, you're dead. I told you not to go over there. Since you went there, okay, you got a job. I want you to sell, you cannot go out of Lincolnville. They're trying to sell papers.
She lined up my shirt. I lined up my bicycle. I went in the next day and it gave me a few papers. I went throughout Lincolnville trying to sell them.
After a period of about two weeks, it didn't work out too well. I'm not on a hot sun. Three, four, five hours a day. I made 10 cents. It wasn't too good. I started thinking, well, maybe I'm not too good at this. I can't make any money. It's not worth staying around making 10 cents. Pretty much most of the day.
This one particular day, I'm thinking, wow, how can I make more money? I'm sorry. You got that big Castillo de San Marcos there in the downtown area, a white area. I know I'm not supposed to go over there, but I need you to give it a shot.
I came over here one day, at the Castillo de San Marcos. I stood in front of the Castillo de San Marcos. Within about an hour, I sold every paper I had. I had to go back to the St. Augustine record and get more papers. I came back in an hour. I sold all of those. I went back a third time and got papers.
I sold all of those. People would come out of the Castillo de San Marcos and look at me and take pictures. I was a cute kid. I was happy. That first day I worked at the Castillo de San Marcos. I had never made a dollar bill. I had about four or five in my pocket. I couldn't believe it.
This went on for a few weeks. I'd go in and pick up my papers and you'd have a line of white paper boys. I would always be allowed to go right up to the front window and get my papers.
I would say, wow, I guess that treat me great. The only black kid here. I put me up the front line. I get my papers. I didn't see the sign colored. I was only a paper boy at the time. I'd not even wear a race or anything else.
I came in one day and what are the white men this? You sell more papers in three days in this whole group in a week. You said, what are you doing? I just squat and I asked the people to buy the papers.
Before that, I actually see some of the white paper boys on their bikes trying to follow me. I circle around, circle around and lose them. This one particular. I don't get they do follow me. I had two white paper boys to follow me up to the Castillo de San Marcos. They took positions to my left and right.
I always saw people who came out of the Castillo de San Marcos. They would come out and look. They would look at me and look at the two white kids and they started buying paper from them. Either one of the white guys.
Being a tenure rep from what is going on, I'm trying to figure out, I'm looking at my shirt as my shirt dirty. I'm looking at my pants and my pants dirty. I couldn't figure out what was going on but they would come out of the Castillo de San Marcos. They'd take a look and they'd buy from me either one of the white kids.
They'd be in the hands of me. One guy would blow out my hair and blow out my pants. I was pretty sharp looking kid. I never get I sat on the curb there across from the Castillo de San Marcos. I forgot what was going on. I can't understand what was going on.
It happened for a few days until the point I said, look, I see people not going to buy papers from me. I don't know why. I had to find another location. I did find another location. It wasn't as good as the Castillo de San Marcos. I can see the life of a paper boy is only a year or two. I had to look for another work.
I worked throughout St. Augustine in many locations. The only thing you get pretty much at that time was washing dishes, washing pots or cleaning up floors.
I managed to eat out a little living out of it. I kept money in my pocket. I'm in high school now. I'm really disenchanted with the high school. I would challenge my teachers about the books being four or five years old written in. I would always be told, well, just stop making a fuss.
Fortunately for me, my uncle, Edward Norton, who moved in New York with his family, left for a small library of books. At that time, I loved to read. I never get his medical books.
I had a little more advanced education than most of the kids in my high school. I would even challenge some of the teachers with some of the things they would say about the history behind some of the books that my uncle left.
I was considered somewhat of trouble making a rebel rouser. I always thought I was a smart student.
But there was no change. Then I started seeing the way my mother particularly would be treated when she'd come up town, a downtown by clothing, and by goods.
It was always Julia, this. Julia, that. She would respond, miss, so-and-so, and miss that. It started annoying me. Why isn't she being called miss? Why does she always have to call someone miss, a mister?
I started to get annoyed with that. I didn't say anything to hurt, but I was annoyed. They started a program in my high school called the DCT where you would get credits for working outside of school.
I thought it was a joke. I thought the program was a joke. Are they going to give you credits for working? That's all I've been doing since I was 10. So that's why I joined this program, which I did. And teacher approaches me when they answer, well, well, we have to find you a job. I said, I have a job.
Oh, all right. Well, get your employer to fill up this form so that you can get credit for it. And I was working out at a land of stage island with my father at a grocery store there. And I took the form to the owner.
That's what would you mind filling this out so I could get credit in high school for working here. You said, no, you don't want to get involved.
That's why not I've been working for you for the last couple of years. Well, no, I'm not going to sign it. Now, at the time, I'm in about the eighth and ninth grade. And I was doing this guy's accounting.
He showed me how to go into his back and order whatever goods he needed. And I was doing that plus stocking groceries. And he was only paying me $40 for working pretty much a 50 day week. I mean, 50 out a week. And he refused to sign. I said, I'll tell you what, I quit. I'll get another job. And he said, oh, wait a minute. Wait a minute. No. And I was a good worker.
And I was a good worker. It's one thing. Any job I worked, I did it well. And I knew that. And he said, wait a minute. Wait a minute. Let me think this over. That's well, there's nothing to think over. I'm just asking you to fill the form. It's nothing out of your pocket.
So he came in a proper form. And I was started getting credits upon credits upon credit. I always worked. I had to work. I was staying with my great grandmother.
I didn't know poverty, but I know we didn't have much. And I tried to help out as much as I could. But I was still upset about the treatment, not only myself, my parents, my father also was working the same grocery. He wasn't making that much.
My mother, the most she could find was tourists work or some menial job. So I always growing up wanting to do something about that. I didn't know what to do. I had to do it.
So I would go to, I started going to Florida Memorial College. Like I said, it was only pool in town for blacks. A couple of my friends at high school, drowned in a sinkhole behind R.J. Murray High School.
I used to jump off the pier with a little bridge coming from West Augustine into Lincolnville. It's a little crossover. I record jumping off that pier with four or five of my friends. One dead drown in there. But there was no place for kids to swim. Black kids in particular.
So at least the college memorial opened up their pool in the summer to a lot of the black kids. Now that's when I got involved with listening to some of the young male college students talking about demonstrating, talking about civil rights and talking about doing something about it. It intrigued me.
I was born in 1948. I actually started getting involved when I was about 14 or 15. Like I said, it intrigued me. I asked, okay. What I do recall is the training that they gave some of the kids.
It's a came there. And one was, yes. You know, they embraced nonviolence as a tactic. So did I. But I think the ear at the time. And my ear at the time was leaning more toward some of the more, I wouldn't say radical. But the more direct speakers like Stokely Carmichael and Malcolm X.
I had heard of this, Dr. (Martin Luther) King. I found him to be very informative and passionate. But the understanding derived from the college kids nonviolent, nonviolent demonstration is the way to go.
So that's what we decided. And I decided with them to embrace. Now when the demonstration started here, yes, I remember the kids going up to sit at the counters and what have you. So I told my mother, I'm going to start demonstrating.
She said, well, I don't think it's a good thing. I said, well, mom, we got to do something. I recalled at the time that.
So struggle to get the adults more involved in the demonstrations. I felt that they were like in a trance. I just hocked me to go into the white neighborhood and see the way a lot of the blacks were being treated. That's why somebody's doing something. I say something.
So I just say myself, maybe they had a trance or something. Maybe it's so used to this particular way of being treated. It's at the point it doesn't bother them.
And I used to try to talk to my mother about it. But again, you just let it go. Just let it go.
Of course, it's so much more to lose.
I don't think it was much to lose. I mean, there was there wasn't anything here. I mean, the way blacks survived in Lincolnville at the time. It wasn't for the black businesses along Washington Street.
Most of the blacks said, a menial jobs weren't paying anything. It was more slave labor than labor. I mean, just to think about how my family eat a living, amazes me to this day.
And I guess the only thing was available was tourists, court work or taking care of some white families kid.
That was pretty much most of what blacks, particularly non professionals had to the deal with.
Now, my mother was working for this white lady out on Anastasia Island now. And I'm still trying to eat a living myself and doing little things.
I was also cutting grass. My great grandmother helped me to get a lawnmower. And I cut grass on the side.
So this, my mother asked me, my white friend, I think she was cleaning her house and keeping her kids at the time, needs her grass.
And if I drop you up at a cutter grass, you think you could do it. I said, yeah, all right, it was a hot day, extremely hot day.
I said, okay, mom, that's your friend. I said, I normally charge $15 to cut an average yard. But since it's your friend, I'll charge a 10.
So my mother drove me out with my lawnmower, dropped me at this lady's house, introduced me. And I convinced her cutting her yard.
It's very hot. So the lady comes to her drive when she calls me, Purcell, would you like a cool drink and a sandwich?
Now, say, yes, thank you, ma'am. I'm a polite of her. And when it was repaired, she came to a garage entrance again.
And so I, Purcell, you come in there, it, everything's made. So I came to the entrance of a garage and I'm looking at this wall.
Where, where, where's the sandwich in the, the sandwich ring? And she said over there.
So when I walked up, she had sit it down next to her dog, dog's tray, dog food on this side, my sandwich and water on the other side.
So I looked at this woman, I said, hmm, boy, okay, what this mentality, what is with these four?
So I said, look, miss, can I use your phone? And she said, well, what's the matter? I said, look, please, may I use your phone?
She said, okay, so she allowed me to come in a house and I called my mother and I explained to my mother what had just happened.
And I could hear the frustration in her voice. She said, could you please put her on the line?
So I did this, my mother wants to talk to you. She said, you know something, miss, so and so on. So I thought you was my friend.
I cannot believe that you would treat my child this way.
I can't believe you would treat any child this way. She said, look, I tell you what, I'll be over there picking him up immediately.
Which I'm very saddened what you just did. So the woman tried to apologize. She said, no, don't worry.
So she did. She gave me, she picked me up and we got back to our home and she said, she said, now I can see what you've been trying to explain to me.
Just the way people treat you. I can see now. And that's when she started getting involved.
Excuse me, we're back on it for short break. Let me just introduce quickly. Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling is with us for the interview as well.
And we may be rejoined by Mr. Conway's wife June as well as the afternoon progresses, please.
Okay, so I hyperticipated a number of marches with my mother insisted that I promise not to get arrested.
Because there would be no one to, I was living still with my great-great-grandmother. And I tried to tend her and need just best I could.
So she wanted to make sure that there was always someone there with her and she asked me, please, just don't get arrested.
I don't mind you demonstrating. I said, okay, mom, I won't get arrested. So I made sure on all the marches that I stayed near the rear.
And sometimes that didn't work because too often I was chased by the police. They could never catch me. But no, I never got arrested.
And good thing. Because one particular night my mother, my father, and my three brothers were all arrested.
So I was only one out of jail. It's a good thing. I guess I was there with my great-great-grandmother.
But my parents were very active. My mother was very passionate. And my father was very supportive. And my brothers too, they were out there.
I think at one point in St. Augustine amongst black households it was a badge of honor to be arrested for the movement. And that was that passion.
And I think when the adults saw what was happening with the young, with their children and the teams out there they got motivated and totally committed.
You knew your classmate of Samuel White?
He was one year below me, yes. His brother James White was, you know, in the same home-room class.
How did young people your age kind of move through that period of time when peers were incarcerated as they were?
Or what do you, well, you know, my own personal feeling is that, you know, we as young adults saw what the system of segregation was.
Our parents had lived under it. We were growing up in it. We decided to the death. We're not going to live this way. Sorry.
I mean, we're going to push it as far as fear. I think fear had nothing to do with it. I think when you live under oppression for so long, particularly seeing your parents live through it.
And now you're coming up through it. My thing was I, at 15, I'm going to do this for my future and my children's future.
Now, it means getting out there to the death. I'm committed. And I think that was the attitude of a lot of the young folk in high school with me.
And people talk about fear. You know, like I say, when you get fed up to the point of being mistreated that fear no longer exists for you is just doing something the anger is just doing something to break free of these chains and this oppression.
And that's what it was. Sacrification.
What memories come sharpest to your mind when you think about that long period of extended demonstration of protest?
No, I was stupid. I was glad. Sorry, I know I eat my words. That's funny. I got all these people helping me out. I'm thinking I'm being helped not realizing that a movement has started out there.
I wasn't too much into the national forefront of the political ends of this, but I was just amazed with Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling.
When I finally got to know who he was and Dr. (Martin Luther) King (Ralph) Abernathy, Hosea Williams and all these people started coming around. I was like a flower in a wall.
I mean, they probably never noticed me that I tried to sleep in the background, but yes, I would sit around and listen as best I could with what they had to say and what they were talking about.
I was just a lady just to be out there to help. And yes, I particularly now recall after this, so right now it was passed around where we were kind of pressed to get people to go out to test the newly enacted.
The newly enacted law. And we did have people coming in from out of town a lot.
I went out myself on one demonstration, St. Augustine Beach. And with a group of four other teens and this white man.
He told me so tall white man. I think his name was Al Lengo. He told me so through the beach.
And we were in the surf maybe about 10, 15 minutes when you can see this large crowd of whites coming from north and south.
They were converging on our location. And we weren't too along because they were at a distance. They kept getting closer and closer.
So Mr. Lengo said, I guess we better get back in the car and leave.
It was a young teenage girl with us, a black girl. And she was running back to the car with his face as she could.
Now we were just casually running back. She got back to the car before us. And she locked all the doors.
And we could not get her to open. And we had enough time to get in the car and drive off. We kept pleading.
Open the door, open the door. And she was just hysterical crying. She was just frightened.
Just crying, boo, we kept pleading. Open the door, she wouldn't open the door.
So we had a crowd finding converged around the car. We were out.
So I don't want to. So I told her, so I'll get on one side of the car.
And they were taunting. They were threatening. They went to one truck and they pulled out angular weights.
Their intent was to bound them out of our hands and feed and take us as far out into the service.
And drop us. And I recall standing there thinking, well, Lord, I didn't think I'd go out this way.
Now, like I said, non-fellowns was a tactic. My life on the line, you coming out to me? I want to make sure that I leave a mark.
That was my thing. I was pretty much self-trained. What I thought was a little karate at the time.
So I swiped. Well, first guy that comes at me, I got to do what I got to do.
But I thought about it slowly one time. Well, maybe a run here or there might help.
I said, look, I have no white neighborhood. I would know it would run.
There's no place to run. I mean, he's all white for.
And at that time, my mindset was that most of the whites just hate black people.
I had a long life, but it just hate us. So I had very little trust for pretty much whites at that time,
sort of this man that we were with. And I'm just, well, maybe this is God's will.
So this is God's will. I have to accept it.
But one white kid walked past me and he punched me in the face.
I cut my lip over. I started to jump. I mean, you had a large mob. There were bats and chains.
And the way to my own lingo put it saying across my chest and told me to stand my ground.
Don't fight back. Stand your ground. So it was hard as that was. I did.
And then he was hit. I recall over the head with a pipe.
The blood hit me in the face. And he collapsed pretty much unconscious next to me.
And at that time, now, you could hear at a distance, a police car sowing.
You could hear it. And seconds passed, the other sound grew louder and louder.
Until that a distance, I could see coming from the south, hit it in North, this police car.
This one loan police car. And as they got closer, the mob dispersed.
Because I think they felt they had killed this white guy out that they hit.
I think they, I thought the guy, I thought I heard his head crack open.
But they, they dispersed.
Help was called. He was taking the hospital and we were taking back to Washington Street.
And I never get Hosea Williams was so angry. He said,
oh, they think they're going to scare us away from the beach.
We're going to come back stronger. So with that, a second demonstration was organized.
And a large group, it occurred about two weeks later, went back to St. Augustine Beach.
And I recalled getting off the bus, a cordon of helmeted police that we walked down between to the water.
And I think I forget the pastor's name that was leading the front of the march.
But who I was in charge of, the group was at that time, came over to the group.
This time I made sure I was going to be in the front. That's what I got to go today.
I'm going to jail. I mean, I'm going to be in the front of this march.
Because I was still upset. I was hitting the face and, I mean, what have you.
But this police, when they, the group approached the front of the group,
and he told us, well, a little problem before you can get into the water,
we have to clear it of all these hostile lights in the water.
So give us a few minutes to clear it. But I assure you you will go into the ocean today.
The state trooper.
The state trooper. So we stood down on the edge of the surf.
They went in just about waist deep. Florida state troopers, to force this angry mob out of the water.
I have never, to this day, seen a milley like it occurred that day.
The wipes in the water had two by fours, chains, bats, and the fight was on.
I mean, it lasted to me about 15, 20 minutes.
But the the Klan in their sympathizers were beaten into submission by white troopers.
I could not believe it. Now I'm really confused now because I'm saying, wow, I can't stand these white men beating up the other white men.
That's a new one for me. I was really shocked. But it was a milley.
They were knocking some of the the Klan, and their sympathizers out and dragging them up to the shoreline and dropping them and going back in for more.
When I say they were beaten into submission, believe me, I said, then watch it. I could not believe it.
And when it was over, the man in charge of these state troopers came back up to our group.
He said, look, okay, I think it's safe for you to go in now. I can't guarantee the quality of the water.
But it is safe for you to go in now.
He actually made that job.
He did. He said, rightfully so. Now, when I went through the edge, I looked at the water. I mean, it was bloody.
I mean, the blood was that thick in the water.
A few of the demonstrators did go around and go into the surf for a few minutes.
But it was so bloody. I was just going through it. I said, no, this water is too bloody.
And I mean, bloody. And I stood there thinking, I'm still kind of confused now.
I mean, these white men fight another white men for my civil rights. I'm trying to figure out for some of my seniors I had.
I'm confused. I had a shifting. I couldn't. I had to put that together. And it took a while.
But I do recall going on demonstrations, marches, or sit-ins, or now to test the law after that.
When these state troopers told the the Klan of their sympathizers to move, believe me, after that beating on the beach that day, they moved. That's one thing I do recall.
How did you ultimately explain it? Why did that happen?
The troop was coming down. And taking that action.
I guess it was. I think they were ordered down here from Farris Bryant.
Governor just decided we're just going to not keep having this happen.
Right.
We just find work and move on.
Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling is mentioning also the (US) Justice Department.
There were these wider forces coming down to stop the early pattern of violence.
There's always a lot of people involved.
There's kind of, I think, I don't need to cut you out there.
Maybe more to say on that. But I also, I would be very appreciative of it.
You could sort of double back and contextualize that moment by talking for a minute or two about the previous pattern of local law enforcement engagement with the Klan and in the context of these demonstrations.
Well, my vantage point, I, oh, I could, what I realized was that the police were not sympathetic to the demonstrated.
And just the opposite.
And again, having been involved with a couple of situations involving the police.
No, my biggest fear was if I was ever arrested, I'd probably be beaten by the local police.
But fortunately, I was never arrested.
I had a situation where, again, being involved at a tutorial school on Washington Street.
The young lady had a class of youth.
I think the oldest body being a six or seven.
She decided to take a small group to the movie theater here downtown.
I didn't think of it wise. It's like I said, this is not the passage of civil rights act.
And I cautioned, I said, look, I don't think it's a good idea.
Oh, we'll be okay. She was by herself.
But anyhow, I decided to hang around in front of the church of the edge of Washington Street there for a couple hours until the safety return from the moon.
Within 20 minutes, I could hear a kid scream.
So I walked again, you know, over to the one block over where the St. Augustine record is located, considered to be a white area at that time.
If you made it back to Washington Street, you were safe. That was a black area.
And I could see the kids running towards me screaming, hysterically.
And this young white female who had taken them to the movie, she's got one kid in a hand and she's trying to write.
And I see this white male on a bicycle with a knife chasing them.
Now, I intervened and stopped.
Unfortunately, I was surrounded by two hulking policemen.
And I felt, well, they're probably going to beat me up.
But they had a police dog.
So I guess they get me.
But I could see the crowd on Washington Street gathered and looking over.
And a couple of friends of mine came up to the policemen and said, well, what are you doing?
You told them you little niggas get away from there.
No, that's our friend. What are you doing?
Then we take to get away from it.
So one of the young men pushed the policemen and took off running.
So the policemen were so upset at that.
They started chasing my two friends and left me there.
But before one of the cops left, he told his dog, if he moves, kill him.
So the dog sat and started growling.
I said, oh, wow.
The German Shepherd and the policeman could not catch my two friends.
So I could see them headed back toward me.
And I'm looking at the dog. He's growling.
I'm looking at the policeman approaching me.
The dog's growling. That's what I had to make a decision.
So I said, well, what I'm going to do is I'm facing the dog and Washington Street is at my back.
I must turn slowly and run as hard as I can back to Washington Street.
This is only a good block to run.
The Ford or the policeman get it.
And so I slowly turn the dog as well in the whole time.
And I took off as fast as I could.
As hard as I could run back to Washington Street.
When I get there, people are waiting. They were clapping.
So I tried to run a look. The dog didn't even move.
He was still sitting there.
So now I'm talking to police. Yeah, come over here now. Come get me. Come get me.
Anyhow, some of the folks are, look, you better go ahead and go home, which I did.
Now I hit out for a while.
Two days actually in one of the church shards.
And people from the community would come by and give me water and sandwiches.
You hit out in the church yard because you thought the police were going to find you.
Yes. And take it. Yeah.
You hit out in the church yard. Yeah. Two days.
Two days, two nights. They would bring the water and sandwiches.
They don't worry about anything. Your parents, we throw your parents everything is safe. We'll take care of you.
When it happened inside the movie theater, it drives better.
I never found out.
But I like I say, we're only talking months after the passage.
So a lot of people were felt everything was okay and no need now to continue to demonstrate or to test the law.
You mentioned there was a white student, young adult, I guess, doing this tutoring of young black children.
And she had taken them into this movie theater.
Yes.
Obviously there were some whites from Northern colleges.
Other contexts came down and had different roles in some way in their way.
Did you did that involvement of whites?
You mentioned Mr. Langel earlier in the beach incident.
How do you take the measure of these white folks who would get involved?
Well, believe it or not, those college kids, white, and they were pretty good group.
Those white college kids changed my perspective of whites.
I thought all whites hated me and other blacks just because we were black.
But they changed my perspective.
You had one particular college student, Gail Blattenberg.
I recently contacted her about two months ago.
And through emails.
But she was like a mother in the end of it.
She was only a few years older.
But surprisingly, she's a story.
You had a group of kids from certain states in the North.
She was from Princeton, New Jersey at the time.
You had some other kids from Massachusetts, all of it.
So what they did when their tutorial session was over here in St. Augustine,
they invited a group of black kids who participated in the program back to their homes.
And my mother didn't want me to go.
She's too young.
I'm sorry.
I can't let him go.
I was a little bit greedy with my mother, my employees.
I like to go.
It was a two-week trip.
She wouldn't.
She's a no.
I'm worried about you.
I don't know too much about the North.
And I don't want you to go up there by yourself with these kids.
And they were young students themselves.
But anyhow, surprisingly, they made up picket signs and picket.
They were like, hey, I'm going to go to the house to try to get my mother to relent
and let me go for that two-week trip with them.
Everybody was a laugh.
This is one of these kids on a picket in the car.
But my mother would come home every day and see where the laugh.
She thought it was very funny.
So finally, she would let it in and allow me to go on that two-week trip.
But I stayed with the Gil Blatt and Berg and her parents.
And what a trip it was.
It's a very good trip.
It changed my whole perspective of white folk.
Because the only white folk I knew was the ones here in St. Augustine, pretty much.
And again, like I see, not that they were nasty,
it's just the way the treatment like you were subhuman or something.
I mean, no respect.
That's what I had.
But those college kids coming on, you had a totally different perspective.
Taking you through late 64 or 65, 66 and how you found your way through that period,
your perspective on St. Augustine is it's reacting to the Civil Rights Act's passage
to the Voting Rights Act of 1965 the next year to...
It took a while for...
I mean, we may be talking a year to kind of get into the...
The mindset of the business community here, the white business community.
But yes, all right, this is the law and you have to adhere to it.
Now, I never had a problem.
Now, I came to the same movie theater myself.
I never forget to watch one of the James Bond movies with no problem.
Restaurants know my money pocket wasn't that tight.
It started hitting the restaurants.
But, you know, I didn't have a problem.
More at ease now coming to the downtown white area that I had been used probably.
As you move through that early...
That those close months, that close year or two after the heaviest of the...
All these moments charged with so much potential violence, actual violence.
Did you...
How did you deal with all that?
And it's sort of the way I carried forward with you.
Was that something that you were able to step forward and away from without too much difficulty?
Did you feel it or did you...?
Not much.
See, I was...
I didn't think what I...
Most of my friends or fellow demonstrators were doing was of any significance.
I just felt like, hey, this is something that had to be done.
So I didn't place that much importance on it.
But I knew...
I was just happy that we accomplished some things.
I wasn't even aware when I was demonstrating too much about a civil rights act or a Voting Rights Act of 1965.
But I was just happy that these things had occurred.
Now, it would help me.
Now, I want to go into a junior college in Daytona Beach where I met my wife who was going to Bethune-Cookman.
It was a trade school.
Now, I took up a brick masonry.
We had a black instructor.
The class pretty much was predominantly black.
It was the first two-year course for the first year and a half.
We were scheduled to go in and take our final exam with, I think, some city agency in Daytona Beach.
Now, in the year and a half, we were there, the black students.
The last six months, you had these two white students that come into the course.
And within a few months, they were allowed to go take the test and become a mason.
And my teacher was outraged.
He said, wait a minute.
What do you...
What do you mean that the only people...
These guys are not even trained. They're only been here a few months.
I got these young black men I've trained for the last year and a half.
And you mean to tell me, you're not going to allow them to go and take the test of finals so they can get their permits and what have you?
School of the Ministry of Reviews.
My instructor, through pro-testing, was fired.
We were called to the Ministry of Office and offered a settlement
because we had a year and a half under this course that if we wanted our certificates, two years certificate,
that we'd have to spend the last six months in a carpentry class.
And believe it or not, two white guys even though only had three months of training, they were given their certificates at work in the construction.
We all refused.
So I never received, even though I did a year and a half, a day to a beach community college in their program.
I'd never received anything for it.
We weren't even reimbursed.
So that was the end of that.
But fortunately, I married and my wife was from New York.
We moved back with herf parents in New York and I got employment there.
But racism, I found, was not just a southern issue.
It was worse in the north.
At least in the south, it was overt in the north that's a pet on the back and a smile on the face.
In a stab you, as often as I can.
I worked in post office my first five years.
Again, here I am doing a counting for a supervisor.
Who can even do it?
But he's being paid more money just to be over the blacks.
Excuse me.
Fortunately, the Civil Rights Act was important in its passage because it did open the floodbed.
I would put it that way for black opportunities, particularly in the north.
Most of the people I went in with in the post over the time were pretty much because of the Civil Rights Act.
But I always looked for advancement and opportunities that there was very little in the post office.
I tried to petition for the take exams to know a veil.
But after five years I passed police department's test and went into that.
Were you in New York City?
Yes.
Now there, the racism was just as rampant.
And I would say more intimidating because it's more of a rank and file organization as you know, police.
You got your sergeant, Lieutenant, Captain, on up.
But somebody high-awky that I worked under felt like I was still some type of nigger that they could talk to anyway wanted.
Again, like I said, that's what my training, my involvement in Civil Rights here in the Civil Rights Act prepared me for that.
It's like I didn't allow the disrespect regardless of who you were when I was a teen.
I didn't allow it working in the police department.
So my attitude was you curse me out no matter what your rank.
I would likewise in turn speak as you speak to me.
You know, I respect your rank as long as you respect me as a human being.
And I did run into some, a lot of, with that attitude, you had, oh boy,
some of the worst of the worst out to you.
But another thing was for sure, from me, most of the guys, particularly blacks that I entered the police department,
when it came out of the Civil Rights Movement, surprisingly.
And we were cohesive and they were as demanding for respect as I was.
Some more so.
So that made it a lot easier.
I was proud to see a lot of the folk and the females, black females were the ones.
I mean, they did not take any shit.
So let's see if I can put it that way from there.
So curious because I think that getting these jobs, I can see that the racism involved,
what's the try to still keep you as low as possible.
And it didn't work because a group, I got together with a group, the Suits, the police department,
and the city of New York for discriminating on the promotional exams.
And we were successful.
I again had the suit with the same similar suit for my lieutenants exam, and we were successful.
And those lawsuits were used, the criteria was used around the nation.
And they were still being used at this day.
So yes, the Civil Rights Movement in Augustine prepared me well.
Did the department change gradually in your service there over time?
Did you think it changed because of this ongoing pattern of challenge and activism?
Definitely. I think the change came about not so much willingly.
The first lawsuit, I guess the New York City Police Department, when it came to the sergeants test,
produced, and this is what changed the complexion of the job.
It produced over 300 minority candidates.
Now they called us quota sergeants at the time.
And the theory was that we couldn't perform, we were given a break, and it was just the contrary.
Now I left my position as a lieutenant with honors.
I trained most of the people that worked under me, particularly white candidates.
And well, to this day I respected.
And my whole focus to them was you treat, you see a woman out there, black, white, green, or blue, you treat her like your mother.
You know, I don't expect you to bring this white mentality into a black neighborhood on how to treat people.
And if I ever see or hear of any of the guys I train treating someone harshly, you have to deal with me.
Don't worry about someone looking you up under your apartment doing an investigation, because I'll be the first to drop a dime on you.
I'll be the first to put you on a foot.
So honestly, honestly, I never, I trained hundreds.
I never had a serious complaint of any white male or female officer under my supervision, never in my career.
Did you come back to say, obviously, in those years?
Yes, I would come every year.
And my parents were still here, my brothers, my family was still here.
So I'd bring my kids down every summer just to give me a wife of break.
And they loved it.
And surprisingly, I know you're talking about the YMCA when they would come down.
My mother would put them in this women program at the YMCA.
Let's take a break for just one second.
Okay, we're back after short break.
I just, I was asking about your return business in Augustine over the years, family here, and much kids down and all.
How did your opinion of the city and racialism to the city evolve over time?
How can you sort of track that for me?
Well, not living here in St. Augustine.
I can't give an opinion, but what I'm really disheartened at the non-improvement of black life here in St. Augustine.
I would come back to see abandoned houses, drug ravaged areas, particularly black seniors not receiving assistance.
To keep their properties up.
I started seeing what I had witnessed in certain areas in New York at one time, due to red-lining.
And I felt like this is what was happening in St. Augustine.
Blacks couldn't get the loans for their properties.
I knew how the system of red-lining was worked.
It starts with the banks not lending money.
It starts with the Kee of the neighborhood, coupled with the raising of taxes, and then the gentrification.
And this is what has played out in Lincolnville over the last ten years.
What's your sense of the...
You mentioned that very central point about how you experience this here in the movement probably substantially were reflected in the way you approach the challenge of the racial challenges structurally in police work.
And even prior to the community college and the choices you made about how to respond to the injustice of the firing of your instructor and the easy passage of these two white students into credential.
I'm interested in your sense of other ways in which the experience here has been reflected in your life as you've gone forward.
And perhaps as a parent, perhaps as a person who contributes to your community and through professional service in other ways?
Well, this, like some of my experiences growing up here, I was raised by my agreeable grandmother.
I'm not valent, but I'm not passive either.
If I'm put in a position where I have to respond physically, I will.
Fortunately, I was not put in that position in the police department, but I think my determination in will is what was a force that I think protected me pretty much.
I think those around me knew that I would respond.
What I learned as a second level of level manager in the police department is this buddy system, you know, viewed by me as races.
Now, I'm going to stand you taking care of your buddy or your friend, which is not a bad thing, but as a whole.
I mean, when you have, let's say, whites that are in authority that make decisions as crucial to the group.
If everything is going to be based on a buddy system, I started seeing this and I would challenge that with a lot of my white friends.
I say, it's not fair.
You know, when you get someone who is qualified to do the job, you need to put that person first.
I mean, if there's a slot open for a buddy, then you, you know, but I started seeing this mentality of this buddy system pretty much more in place.
And I thought that my white colleagues didn't do that as being races.
And I say, it is because who is your buddy is the guy that you live around, the guy that you drink with?
You're not drinking with me.
You're not drinking with the guys like me.
So that's why you find yourself not putting them on the same scale as your buddy.
So your buddy is always going to make out.
And I think this is the whole, my own personal mind.
So is this the whole makeup of this whole system we live in?
Everything is a buddy system.
It's who you know. It's not what you know.
And that's the way I see it now.
You've moved back to Florida?
Yes.
Yeah, I'm in Palm Coast, FL now.
Did you, did you, would you guess that you would have done that when you moved away?
Yes. You always thought we'd be fine.
I know, I know we were going to come back.
I think we knew we were going to come back.
I mean, who can beat this weather?
If you were a makeup, you would imagine making a walk through the neighborhood here.
And a walk through Lincolnville.
And imagine pausing it a few places because key memories that you haven't shared previously really came out.
What, can you imagine what a few of those stories might be?
My passion now, and this is before the city, is the little links to Gatwood also security Gellimore Center.
That pool has, which I understand was managed by the county for the last few years, has been closed for over two years.
Now, I petition the city commissioners with some historical facts from 15 years ago.
And I hope they listen.
See, the little links was more than just a park.
It actually was a sanctuary for me, and I'm quite sure a lot of people.
And I think it still is.
I don't know what the cities and tenants in that area, but I hope it is to restore it to its glory and repair and put that pool open for all of you.
I hope it is that way.
I don't know.
All I can do is just continue to fight for that.
But that's one area.
I had so many, many great days.
And I'm quite sure you have quite a few young kids at the time, probably in my age, now they can say that.
That was the only sanctuary you could go to to get away from all this hatred and bigotry and discrimination.
That was it.
You went there, fun, fun, fun all day.
So that's one spot.
I think it actually, in my heart, the only spot.
And just...
Can you put up some meeting and if we can meet after the...
Yeah, Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling has just said that...
Just Conway is leading an ongoing effort to try to reactivate that whole...
The center, we got more center in...
I know that there is much, much more we could talk about.
And you're such a great narrator that you've taken me through a nice arc here.
Are the other things you want to come back to touch upon before we finish other scenes, other moments, other thoughts?
Well, I think...
In a lot of communities, you have a lot of black activism, particularly political.
St. Augustine now is just at that stage of getting there.
I was asked a question, a panel once, why blacks are not involved in city affairs and civic affairs?
And I'll respond the same way.
You cannot keep a race of people out of political spectrum for decades
and expect when you pass an act, a civil rights bill or any other bill, that all of a sudden there's both a flood of gates
and come back in the civic duty.
And I think again, I was not raised into political spectrum, but be a civic minded, just like I'm quite sure, generations,
particularly here in Lincolnville and West Augustine behind me weren't raised.
I think if you know, once those folks understand the importance of it,
you're slot-seeing them returning and being more active with their civic duties.
And that's what I, another thing I've been trying to explain and push.
Successfully, too. I've seen it.
There is a lot more activism than it was a year or two ago.
I see that. I'm really proud of it.
I really want to thank you. It's been a real honor and privilege.
And I, at least thank you again also for the extra flexibility in our day schedule, but it's been great to be with you.
Thank you.
Before we close, it leads to a tribute to Mother Anne and her daughter.
Yeah, I mean, it was to sure I believe you, so for sure, grandly.
Yeah, let me do that. Are we still 100?
Okay.
Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling is suggesting George Conway.
Yeah, Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling suggested that Ms. Conway call out his parents and let me have you name them and talk a little about them before we close.
That's lovely. Thank you.
Yeah, my dear, loving Mother Julia Conway and my dedicated father, George Conway.
I can say, very active.
A passion, my mother's passion, was for her sons.
And to have us excel as best we could.
You talked about one of us, one of her sons. You really got on a nerd.
My father, yes, my father was well known both in the black and white neighborhood.
I was not aware of how loved he was with the white neighborhood.
I wasn't.
When I saw the way he was treated at certain locations and a recent journal of a friend of his,
before my father passed, the way he was treated by his white friends amazed me.
What was it that drew him into contact with the white community?
He did.
He delivered groceries for the grocery store on Anastasia Island. I worked.
So he knew everybody.
I was surprised. He and I and my wife was in one of the local banks taking care of some business.
And they were giving us a hard time, understandably.
And I had the caution of bank manager because it was a court order,
which they were trying to get around.
So I had a caution. So I'm going to go back to the judge and they know that you're not here.
So anyhow, little lad, no.
The judge was walking by so the judge said, George, is everything okay over there?
The bank manager looked, oh, that's judge. So it's a problem.
I said, oh, I don't worry about that judge. We get it.
It's under control. It's just a fact.
And I'm saying, my father, no, he knew everybody just about St. Augustine.
Just behind again on Anastasia Island Island, they knew him like their own father at his side.
And he weathered the consequence of having been a strong supporter of the movement?
Oh, yes. Well, his one story, again, he's working with a grocery store. He was a good one too.
Sorry, I left that out earlier. But the owner decided to fire him for participating in the marches.
Now, the butcher of the store was white.
So the butcher walked up to the answer, I tell you what? If he goes, I go.
So that means the store goes. You know, this guy was a butcher.
And my father was a delivery man.
He was just low for a death because of prejudice.
They were that friendly. And he let them know, no, you're not going to treat George like that.
Not, well, I'm not if he won't be here. So he's thinking, you can threaten him if he goes on a march.
He'll be here. So I guess I'm fired. Well, I can always find somebody to do, okay.
But did a butcher told the owner, if he goes, I'm going.
So it's hard to find a good butcher or a good delivery man. My father, like I see, that store owner just did not know how much love the community on Anastasia Island had for my father.
I didn't know that.
I mean, what about your mother?
My mother, again, like I say, what she's extremely loving, extremely hard working.
It would sad me to see some of the menial things that she was forced to do.
But fortunately, like I say, again, she wound up getting a decent job at Flagler Hospital.
Yeah, against it's very smart woman.
But again, the system just used black folk even after a civil rights act.
I mean, they had her doing nurses doing.
She was training nurses on how to 10 new boards.
And this is something that you learned from your mother, but she was training nurses on when a child had a colleague or something else.
And she also said, my mother would give them home remedies at work.
So again, she, when they had, they put her in pediatrics, the pediatrics section, but refused to the payer, probably.
And, but they would get the credit for things that she would do.
And she was a loving, particularly, she loved babies.
Newborn, she has that with her passion.
She said, then rock them all in late.
And the nurses would say, oh, you got them late.
You sit down and rock that kid.
Well, I don't want to hear him crying all night.
So I'll sit here and I get some time and rock them asleep.
But she was, again, she was loved on the job.
They treated her unfairly.
They fired her before her 10th year.
This thing with trying to get some little pension out of these jobs back then was just, it was insulting.
You had approached her 10 year, how much was a little pension?
You can get something from a job.
They would fire.
They'd find a reason to fire.
Black or white.
Pensions were the scurry of life here when I was growing up.
That's why I left Florida.
In my readings, I knew, wow, you get a pension more job.
At least you get something that you can lean on when you get older.
So that's what attracted me to the north.
Unfortunately, I feel I was successful in landing some pretty decent jobs and acquiring a decent pension.
Thank you, again, it's been a real pleasure.
Thank you so much.
Oh, well, that's okay.
Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling is happy to talk about all the VBs and VBs.
Yeah.
This year alone, he has joined with a corps and with the adult activity to Tallahassee, with his wife and more, to the (Florida) Florida Clemency Board.
And then he feels back to Tallahassee and I spoke as the capital in Louis, London, on the activity test of this life.
Conference.
Let us read his call.
Right.
And draw one of the VBs and a VB.
Yes.
And then he feels like this.
Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling, does one of the stuff?
He's leaving out.
Yeah.
I know there's a lot of things to do with what he has.
But all of his contributions and attributes and everything else to didn't stop.
He's now 60.
62?
60.
And he's careful.
All the people in this industry, I think they're almost getting used to it.
Yeah.
The microphones probably couldn't back that up.
But Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling, especially wanted to call out Mr. Conway for all pattern of ongoing service, including participation in the ACCORD effort on the currency issue of the Tallahassee in the state capital.
And so obviously it's been the relationship that's been a very usually.
And I like that one thing.
One thing I am totally, totally amazed at this organization, the ACCORD.
I mean, they Mrs. Gwendolyn Duncan and her family took this task on by themselves some years ago in the old three.
And so much.
I would say has done everything to highlight the efforts of the civil rights movement here in St. Augustine.
They're focused on this.
And I like to say again, my neighbor again, Mrs. Barbara Vickers.
I recall when she took on her loan test of trying to make a monument for the foot soldiers.
So these, these folk by themselves have done these great works.
And like I said, you see the monuments.
And you see the, the dedications of the ACCORD, but in all I can do is praise and thank them.
They are again, other future foot soldiers, the civil rights movement, and making it known to the nation and the world.
I like to thank them.
Thank you so much.
And all over the tribal one, three, nine, cross the border.
All over the Laplace area.
Dr. (Robert B.) Hayling pointing out that that's worth it.
All been essentially a volunteer basis 501 C3 that's a good view.
But we're going to stop there.
Thank you all.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.